moins de 24 heures après de nouveaux
coups de feu rue de fribourg dans le
quartier planoise
la vie reprend son cours tranquillement
les guetteurs sont déjà là les clients
et les trafiquants aussi dès 10 heures
du matin ce jeune homme aux scooters qui
nous dit avoir 17 ans a repris son
activité de revente de drogue non pas
par envie
mais selon lui par dépit vous voudriez
travail et voudriez faire autre chose
explique et moi le petit peu merci rené
robert fait autre chose c'est pas une
vie
il revêt travailler tranquille c'est
comme ça quand vous cherchez du travail
ça se passe comment ça ne prend pas or a
noté ça nous prend pas un papa diplôme
padilla rien fait durant ce moment
hier soir vers 18h30 un petit groupe de
jeunes et rassemblés rue de fribourg
quand un scooter surgit cinq à six coups
de feu sont tirés dans leur direction
deux adolescents de 13 à 17 ans sont
blessés aux jambes chez ma fille qui a
vu tout le tout la scène un petit garçon
qui
qui a été déjouée tirer dessus et puis
il est tombé à terre c'est elle qui a
même appelé impossible pour l'instant de
savoir si les deux jeunes blessés était
directement visé ou si ce sont des
victimes collatérales
mais pour cette maman qui vit depuis 20
ans dans le quartier
la priorité c'est désormais la
protection de ses quatre enfants
au milieu de cet environnement difficile
ils sortent pas du tout parce que j'ai
peur quand j'ai l'aîné qui a 17 ans et
un garçon et puis c'est pareil tous les
jeunes qui sont en voilà
qui vont les guetteurs et tous et des
copains dans le fond ça va nous enfin
quand j'ai je protège mieux si ça repas
depuis un mois des effectifs de crs sont
présents dans le quartier chaque nuit de
19h à 1h du matin mais pour les
riverains
ça ne suffit pas il faut la sécurité il
faut la police qui tombe toute la nuit
ça fait 40 ans que je suis là j'ai gommé
gosses ont grandi ici sont nés ici
moi je travaille à plein droit j'ai pris
ma retraite ici à planoise ma vie et les
aplats l'oise
l' enquête a été confiée à la police
judiciaire de besançon
des auditions sont en cours et les
images de vidéosurveillance sont
analysés depuis le mois de novembre
neuf personnes ont été blessées par
balles dans le quartier planoise